mihail shoe Maha remains in a critical
condition Formula One's most successful
ever driver is still fighting for his
life at this hospital in grenoble the
hospital says the former f1 champions
life is still in danger Shu maha was
unconscious when he was admitted to the
hospital on sunday he was suffering from
severe brain trauma doctors performed
emergency surgery to try and relieve the
pressure on his brain he's still in an
induced coma Dooley tech monkee some
Thai don't like all the treatments
currently recommended are in place it
could pull him amor we cannot say
anything on what will happen to me
Hailsham aha the Michael Schumacher the
news has sent shockwaves around the
sporting world former driver Olivier
pani visited the hospital to offer his
support gambusia good I've been
listening to the news like you I live
here so I came to see him well don't
over cetera Schumacher was with his son
in the French Alps resort of Meribel
when the accident happened they were
skiing off-piste when chamaka fell and
hit his head on a rock he was wearing a
helmet but that wasn't enough to fully
protect him from the force of the crash
so casket up hoodie the helmet protected
him a little without that he wouldn't be
here now dude accidents on cask ceptin
on skype ID very stinky see people in
Chewbacca's hometown of campin are
coming to terms with the news of his
accordance he took so many risks and it
all went well then he has a skiing
accident it's unbelievable to us device
he was a really great driver I'm sorry
for him took me a light beam these are
crucial moments for one of Formula One's
all-time greats